sans ce public continue dans cette
émission on veut vous le savez vous
informer sur le contenu les propositions
des candidats des candidats à la
présidentielle et chaque jeudi ont
choisi un grand m aujourd'hui c'est
l'école demandez le programme
l'école c'est structurant souvent
clivant dans une campagne
un moyen pour les candidats de se
distinguer avant d'en débattre les
propositions les plus marquantes résumé
par cécile sexo si marine le pen ne pas
encore dévoilé son programme les autres
candidats déclarés eux s'accordent tous
sur un point il faut donner plus de
moyens humains et financiers à l'école
yannick jadot et jean luc mélenchon
propose de recruter des enseignants
65000 sur cinq ans pour l'écologiste
60000 pour le candidat et les filles il
propose également une hausse des
salaires comme la candidate socialiste
anne hidalgo elle souhaite élever la
rémunération d'entrée des professeurs
des écoles au même niveau que celui des
cadres c'est professeurs des écoles
démarrent leurs grilles indiciaires leur
carrière à 1700 euros alors qu'ils sont
bac +5 qu'un bac +5 en france et
recruter environ autour de 2300 euros en
début de carrière donc on amène à ce
niveau de recrutement à droite valérie
pécresse eric zemmour défendent les
valeurs d'une école républicaine la
candidate et leur propose de rétablir
l'ordre en poursuivant systématiquement
des élèves ou parents qui agressent des
professeurs elle défend également le
passage d'un examen d'entrée en 6ème
avec des classes de remise à niveau et
la mise en place d'une réserve éducative
je vois aussi la pluie sur une réserve
éducative nationale comme il ya une
réserve de la gendarmerie nationale
réserve éducative nationale que je vais
créer que je vais rémunérés pour
accompagner l'aide aux devoirs et le
soutien scolaire eric zemmour produit le
retour de la blouse à l'école et du
latin et du grec en sixième quant à
emmanuel macron qui n'est toujours pas
officiellement candidat il vante ses
réformes comme la scolarisation
obligatoire à 3 ans et le dédoublement
des classes en zep de cp et de ce1 ils
pourraient proposer une réforme du
collège c'est en tout cas ce que défend
son ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer
demandez le programme quelle école pour
demain débat 100% politique avec
nathalie et limaces bonsoir bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
chargé de l'éducation prioritaire laure
darcos bonsoir sénatrice l air de
l'essonne vice présidente de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication ici au sénat
yannick triomphe bonsoir soir est
secrétaire nationale éducation au ps
conseiller régional d'île de france et
membre de l'édicule éducation d'anne
hidalgo on a également avec nous en
visioconférence en duplex jean frédéric
poisson quai président de via la voix du
peuple et porte parole d'eric zemmour
bonsoir bien à vous aussi évidemment
laetitia accrue pas et rester à mes
côtés alors ce que je vous propose d'en
dans ce débat c'est de m'appuyer sur les
principales propositions alors c'est
assez subjectif des choix que nous on a
fait la rédaction de vos candidats c'est
vrai qu' on est également dans
l'actualité puisqu'il ya de nouveau une
grève des syndicats d'enseignants
aujourd'hui relativement peu suivi 9% de
profs mobilisés on va sortir de cette
actualité sortir des débats autour du
protocole sanitaire vraiment pour entrer
dans les propositions on va aussi
s'appuyer sur des réactions et une
première réaction tiens celle de
l'écrivain erik orsenna il participait
hier à l'agora d'éducation ici au sénat
il parle de l'ascenseur social détraqué
les des termes qui l'emploie c'est une
assignation à résidence
ans
ce qui au delà de la question des
inégalités qui est un des mots que je
vois partout en france pire que
l'inégalité c'est le manque d'espérance
on sait en naissant qu'on n'a pas le
droit à l'espérance dans l'immense
majorité c'est à dire qu'on est assigné
à la résidence sociale est ce ça c'est
absolument insupportable
et évidemment comme vous l'avez dit on
attend beaucoup de l'école on attend de
l'école que l nous sorte de ça et c'est
pas du tout évident que la voie du
mérite soit aussi ouverte contre x
l'atelier limaces je commence avec vous
et évidemment et même à qu'on n'est pas
encore officiellement candidat donc on
n'est plus dans le dans le débat que
dans les propositions mais vous si on
fait un bilan sur ce point particulier
réparer l'ascenseur social question vous
mettez en avant déjà je vous remercie
effectivement de rappeler que je suis ce
soir dans une position un peu singulière
puisqu'on effet emmanuel macron et
président de la république et ne
toujours pas déclaré et donc vous à nous
allons débattre des propositions portées
par vos candidats et moi effectivement
je serai davantage sur le bilan mais en
tout cas pour réagir à ce que ce petit
passage
le secrétariat d'état dont j'ai la
charge a été créée en juillet 2020 sous
l'impulsion du président la république
par la volonté également bien sûr de
jean michel blanc coeur et c'est la
première fois quand même sous la vème
république qui lie à un secrétariat
d'état dédié à l'éducation prioritaire
et ma boussole depuis bientôt presque
deux ans un an et demi en tout cas c'est
vraiment l'égalité des chances et de
lutter contre toutes les inégalités les
inégalités bien sûr éducative mais aussi
les inégalités sociales et je deviens
soyez en ce sens boxer pour ça que vous
avez public et l'on vous fait le bilan
de l'éducation prioritaire vous voulez
dire qui vous sied à une mesure que
voulait faire ressortir le dédoublement
des classes le dédoublement des classes
de cp de ce1 alors
mais absolument mais bien évidemment je
ne dis pas qu'on n'a jamais travaillé
l'éducation prioritaire avant la
création de ce secrétariat d'état jean
michel blanquer en arrivant
effectivement à dédoubler les classes de
cp et de ce1 moi j'ai poursuivi son
action en dédoublant les classes de
grande section ça c'est si vous me
demandez une mesure vraiment sur les
inégalités éducatives et sur les
inégalités sociales j'en ai une autre
qui est très forte c'est la distribution
des petits déjeuners gratuits à l'école
et là on est à la fois sur de l'éducatif
et on est également sur une jambe très
social et je crois que ça répond en
partie à la remarque d'erik orsenna
alors je vais reprendre ce effectivement
cette mesure dédoublement des classes de
cp et de ce1 laure darcos vous le mettez
au crédit de quinquennat des macros et
de jean michel blanquer parce qu'il est
ministre il est question depuis le début
du quinquennat oui tout à fait et enfin
je pense que même certains prédécesseurs
en l'ont rêvé de le faire simplement ce
n'est pas partout et on en aura vraiment
les conséquences que quand ces enfants
là sont arrivés en sixième et qu'ils
auront en effet acquis ces fameux
fondamentaux c'est pour ça que ma
candidate propose à un examen avant
d'entrer da 6e bien évidemment on
apprend mieux à 30k cave à 15 par donc à
30 la seule chose c'est qu'on reste
encore dans tous les justes e mans
l'éducation prioritaire dont clairet
père est plus fins et des acronymes
c'est une technique les réseaux les
réseaux d'éducation prioritaire moi je
vois arriver un autre initiative qui est
resté au milieu du gué et que j'ai
pourtant beaucoup
poussé qui étaient les sites et
éducatives en fait par exemple je prends
l'exemple de mon département l'essonne
ont été catalogués site éducative les
mêmes villes qui étaient déjà des
réseaux d'éducation prioritaire ou
redonner encore plus de professeurs plus
de moyens à ces mêmes villes vous avez
toute cette frange de villes moyennes ce
qu'on appelle
la banlieue en fait la suburbaine en
fait où là on a qu'on ne leur donne pas
les moyens ou ils ont encore des classes
est extrêmement surchargé et dont pareil
en cp ce1 de la même façon avec peu de
moyens peu de possibilités de trouver
des profs remplaçants en passant on y
reviendra peut-être mais la mesure phare
de valérie pécresse c'est de redonner
beaucoup plus d'autonomie à tous les
chefs d'établissement à tous niveaux de
l'éducation primaire et secondaire pour
qui lisait beaucoup plus c'est
l'attitude de retrouver des vacataires
ou des profs remplaçants proche de jeu
proche de chez eux et qu'il n'y ait pas
cet absentéisme qui est encore
extrêmement fort dans certains coins et
ses sites et éducative - chez moi
j'avais notamment de ville sainte
geneviève des bois et saint michel sur
orge ce sont des maires de couleurs
politiques différentes qui voulait faire
ce projet de site éducatif qui n'ont
jamais pu pour l'instant encore avoir ce
label qui était un
vraiment un projet qui permettait de
replacer les écoles dans l'environnement
communal et départemental pour que les
élus locaux les parents et les
professeurs
les équipes pédagogiques puissent
travailler ensemble donc on est resté là
dessus un peu au milieu du gué alors
alors je c'est un peu c'est un peu bien
entendu
bien compris yannick trigance quel bilan
vous faites on est pour l'instant sur le
bilan de de l'action des manuels macro
et de son ministre de l'éducation
notamment toujours sur cet enjeu de de
mobilité sociale d'ascenseur social tout
d'abord si vous le voulez bien sur la
question du dédoublement j'ai publié il
ya peu de temps une tribune dans un
quotidien du soir monsieur blanc caire
lorsqu'il était arrivé en responsabilité
avait indiqué dès le départ qu'ils ne
changeraient pas forcément tout ce qui
existait la réalité malheureusement à
montrer et l'exemple du dédoublement des
cp et des ce1 est un excellent exemple
puisqu'il existait un dispositif
antérieur qui était le dispositif plus
de maîtres queux de classe plébiscité
plébiscité par les équipes pédagogiques
et qui a été d'un trait de plume rayé
par le ministre blanc caire pour
installer le dédoublement du cpc je
précise simplement du cp je précise
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs les premiers
éléments sur les dédoublements de cp ce1
n'indique absolument pas c'est faux un
impact j'évolue sur la réussite
ultérieure des élèves deuxième élément
c'est que d'un point de vue budgétaire
environ 7000 800 postes ont été pris sur
le second degré dans les lycées et
notamment dans les lycées professionnels
qui sont en grande souffrance pour
pouvoir mettre en place ce cpc
dédoublement cp sur un troisième élément
c'est la formation des enseignants j'ai
été dans une autre vie inspecteur
d'éducation nationale et on n'enseigne
pas à 30 comme on enseigne à 25 ou à 12
or que c'est signé or que s'est il passé
alors dans la mise en place du
dispositif c'est que ce sont des
enseignants donc sans formation qui se
sont retrouvés dans des classes à 12 et
on voit bien voyons que
coupez 12 et parce que
ça signifie que des enseignants sans des
pratiques de classe encore une fois et
tous les rapports de l'inspection le
montre mais on n'enseigne pas on
n'enseigne pas à 12 comme on enseigne à
30 ou à 25 donc on voit aviation se
disent plus facile d'enseigner à 10,90
oui mais c'est pas oui mais on n'en sait
oui mais on n'enseigne pas de la même
manière aux qu'elle était il ya juste
une dernière chose donc pour répondre à
des standards board il ya eu un effet
d'annonce d'accord pour pouvoir agir
allait rapidement dresse sur
l'efficacité juste sur les citations sud
oui sur l'efficacité moi je peux vous
dire je fais des déplacements toutes les
semaines deux fois trois fois c'est un
plébiscite des professeurs des familles
et des élèves et on voit à l'inversé de
ce que vous avez dit monsieur trigance
déjà les résultats dans les classes les
premières cohortes de cp ce1 dédoubler
sont aujourd'hui en classe de cm1 et de
cm2 et les résultats sont déjà
perceptibles et je vous le dis à l'appui
d'éléments très factuelle et objective
et ce sont les évaluations nationales
que nous faisons passer chaque année à
nos élèves et qui montre qu'il ya un
progrès et que l'écart se resserre entre
nos élèves en éducation prioritaire et
en dehors de l'éducation prioritaire
alors je donne la parole maintenant au
jeu je pense que vous voulez
doublement des classes donc on a un
avenir du mans fort à l'un et à l'autre
je voudrais entendre maintenant jean
frédéric poisson avec notamment cette
phrase de votre candidat eric zemmour il
dit que l'école a été laissée aux mains
des pédagogistes depuis quarante ans ça
veut dire quoi ça ça veut dire que
ce qui a été fait dans l'école beaucoup
de niveaux en tout cas enfin le modèle
qui a été promue et parfois même imposé
relève d'une philosophie selon laquelle
les laisse se construit tout seul et
qu'en définitive
l'enseignant un rôle presque connexes ou
pour ne pas dire accessoires dans
l'acquisition des savoirs c'est ça que
ça veut dire et enfin je pense que si
les grands pédagogistes qui avait encore
financière d'il ya longtemps monsieur
meirieu et en leur chef à tous ne
contredirai pas cette cette définition
deux choses me frappent dans d'autres
échanges la première c'est là la force
de la phrase d'erik orsenna tout à
l'heure
moi qui étais un décrocheurs scolaires
extrêmement énergique et tout à fait
performant
je sais pourquoi et comment j'en suis
sorti j'en suis sorti grâce à l'énergie
de mes parents qui n'ont jamais cessé de
me soutenir et grâce à l'énergie est
comment dire à la détermination de mes
professeurs qui étaient déterminés à
m'apprendre les fondamentaux du savoir à
me faire progresser l'acquisition d'une
culture et qui ont toujours considéré
qu' il avait davantage de choses à
m'apprendre que moi à prendre tout seul
et la deuxième chose qui me frappe c'est
que ils font contrer bien l'organisation
de votre débat d'ailleurs je vous
remercie de votre invitation mais je
salue nos convives
celle que au fond ce qui manque et dans
d'autres débats sur l'éducation c'est de
se mettre d'accord sur ce à quoi ça sert
et j'ai l'impression que nous ne sommes
pas tous d'accord sur ça que ça sert
de notre point de vue du point de vue
d'eric zemmour et du mien le premier
rôle de l'école quel que soit le niveau
auquel on apprend auquel on assiste
c'est l'acquisition d'autonomy par le
savoir et c'est à dire que c'est comme
quand on apprend la musique comme élu
local j'ai été responsable d'un
conservatoire de musique vous ne pouvez
pas décemment apprendre la musique et
puis d'une certaine manière et
progresser tout seul et ensuite à
prendre par vous même si vous n'apprenez
pas dans un certain ordre avec des
figures imposées un peu comme au
patinage artistique et c'est là maîtrise
de ses figures imposées qui vous donne
ensuite la possibilité de briller dans
des figures libres je ne crois pas dans
cet objectif prioritaire exclusive de
l'école qui consisterait à former des
citoyens ça n'est pas drôle de l'école
je ne prends pas non plus dans le
discours qui est très libérale beaucoup
trop à mon goût qui consiste à dire que
le rôle de l'école c'est de savoir
désinsertion professionnelle ça viendra
plus tard et ailleurs je crois que on
s'insère dans la société on peut réussir
on peut s'intégrer on peut s'épanouir si
et seulement si on apprend les moyens
d'apprendre tout seul c'est ça qui me
frappe le plus dans d'autres dans
d'autres et chambre légende à moins que
[Musique]
c'est ce que c'est ce que vous mettez en
avant c'est ce que eric zemmour met en
avant c'est aussi ce que
et puis et puis enfin très honnêtement
enfin je suis pas polémiste range dans
général mais je pense que nos amis c'est
présent dit la même chose ce discours on
l'a depuis toujours les fondamentaux
apprendre à lire écrire compter et
respecter autrui on a toujours voulu
alors respecter autrui on pourra y
revenir parce que il faut aussi
respecter ses professeurs et ça c'était
un peu plus compliqué je pense dans ce
quinquennat avec à chaque pas de vagues
et le fait que les professeurs sont
peut-être sentis pas forcément soutenu
comme il fallait mais en tout cas
concernant les fondamentaux bien
évidemment c'est important moi je
rappelle que nicolas sarkozy en son
temps avait
proposé en fait des heures
supplémentaires aux professeurs pour
pouvoir justement faire ses heures de
soutien scolaire propose à nouveau vers
ipcress sous un autre nouvelle nouvelle
formule en fait de prendre des
enseignants retraités qui d'ailleurs
souvent bien évidemment ne se sont
ravisés nationale voilà en fait avec
avec le système du cumul emploi retraite
à 65 ans quand vous prenez votre
retraite vous avez envie de continuer à
être utile et je pense qu'en effet il ya
sûrement une réserve considérable
d'anciens professeurs ça fera plaisir
peut-être à monsieur poisson avec des
vieilles méthodes
bien sûr moment ils seraient payés serez
payés donc et qui permettrait en fait à
faire ses heures de soutien pourquoi
est-ce que je pense qu'on a tous au fond
quand même objectivement ces mêmes
objectifs mais c'est le problème c'est
qu'on appuyé toujours que sur les zones
d'éducation prioritaire je vous dis on
laisse tous les autres et je pense aussi
à toutes les zones rurales et donc le
problème c'est que c'est un vase
communicant on a de moins en moins de
professeurs vous le savez pourquoi parce
que la carrière n'est pas valorisé ont
ils sont très mal payés et c'est
compliqué de revaloriser parce qu'ils
sont tellement nombreux que valoriser
simplement en monnaie sonnante et
trébuchante ça n'est pas évident mais il
faut les amener est peut-être plus
présents dans l'établissement est raide
et justement peut-être par ces retraités
enseignants qui peuvent les aider et on
est tous d'accord pour essayer de faire
le moins de décrocheurs possible à
l'entrée de la sixième est par contre de
ne plus laisser partir et livrés à eux
mêmes en collège ou c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué sans qu'ils aient ses
fondamentaux donc en effet là dessus je
pense qu'on peut tous se rajouter
quelque chose dans le débat politique
qui va vous opposez chacun je sais bien
que vous êtes ici pas encore en
lieutenant de d'emmanuel macro mais
quand même il me semble que deux points
de vue de l'exécutif c'est un peu
restreint cette toujours cesse depuis
cinq ans on entend les zones
prioritaires le dérèglement des classes
il y aura certainement en autre argument
mais si vous voulez je vous fasse
analyse du bilan il est beaucoup plus
vaste que ça en fait je voulais aller
élément il y aura aussi mais on a laissé
on est seul pays à avoir laissé l'école
ouverte dans la critique garde et ses
terrasses et une à quel prix concrètes
et en plus immédiates que le prix mais
il me serait pas l'aider que
c'est à dire que quand on entend en tant
que spectateur avant d'être journaliste
on entend le gouvernement uniquement
nous parler de ce dédoublement des
classes de cp en zone prioritaire mais
ayant toujours maître à jouer et le rsa
mais ya 13 mai mais il ya le reste bien
évidemment notamment la limitation du
nombre d'élèves à 24 hors éducation
prioritaire par exemple très bien sûr
mais sur le reste du territoire et c'est
en train de se déployer ses sites
j'entends dire la mobilisation d'une
réserve citoyenne de professeurs
retraités vous savez que c'est déjà le
cas je crois comprendre en fait que
valérie pécresse réchauffer les plats
soient ceux de nicolas sarkozy ou ceux
de jean michel blanquer a offert du
soutien aux devoirs du soutien de poids
et bien vous savez il existe ainsi
depuis 2010 cette
année beaucoup d'exemples
d'enseignants qui disait les
contractuels on les voit pas et il
fallait donc les 3300 qui ont été promis
à 15 jours en fait et ils sont pas
encore mort où on en est un bout de
réponse alors l'estimation là notamment
et spécifiquement pendant ce mois de
janvier où ça frappe fort dans l'est
dans les écoles même si je précise quand
même au passage qu'à 97% des professeurs
qui sont devant les élèves chaque jour
97% et qu'il y à 96% des classes qui
sont ouvertes le but rendre hommage aux
primaires je rend évidemment hommage au
professeur parce que oui bien sûr la
ligne du gouvernement c'est l'école
ouverte mais nous n'y arrivons que parce
que les professeurs sont là extrêmement
responsable très mobilisé et très engagé
en tout cas l'estimation qui est faite
de professeurs absents là pendant la
crise sanitaire elle est d'environ 10%
et les effectifs sont là pour remplacer
les 10% que ce soit des contractuels des
vacataires ou encore des retraités
auxquels nous faisons
appel et qui bien sûr puisque la
question a été posée je le confirme sont
rémunérés donc ça depuis ce que vous
vouliez réponse précise la voilà et
enfin sur les fondamentaux parce que
j'entends les uns et les autres parler
des fondamentaux je rappelle l'objectif
quand même du dédoublement des classes
c'est bien ça
le des doubles noms mais le dédoublement
des classes c'est l'acquisition solide
des fondamentaux lire écrire compter et
respecter autrui et pâques en éducation
prioritaire mais je pense pourrait en
parler pendant des heures le bilan de
jean michel blanquer est suffisamment
conséquent mais je suis à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions et les triangles sur le bilan
de jean michel blanquer on pourrait y
consacrer
position
des professeurs
vous n'avez vous n'avez certainement pas
à bien écouter y compris son interview
de ce matin moi je suis
je suis heureux de voir qu'aujourd'hui
et notamment donc
du côté de chez madame pécresse que on
parle de brigades de remplacement esther
je rappellerai quand même que
lorsqu'elle était ministre de monsieur
sarkozy sur la question de l'éducation
il ya quand même eu 80 mille postes de
supprimés dans l'éducation nationale et
la formation des enseignants donc je
suis heureux aujourd'hui de constater
que l'éducation revient au premier plan
sur la question d'éducation prioritaire
je regrette et nous regrettons par
exemple la le déficit total de la
scolarisation des enfants de moins de 3
ans en école maternelle qui constitue en
fait
non formidable ans je parle bien j'ai
été non je vous parle de l'année je
viens d'un département que vous
connaissez sans doute qu'il département
de la seine-saint-denis absolument
aujourd'hui même cet abus département de
la seine-saint-denis il n'y a quasiment
plus d'enfants de moins de trois ans qui
sont scolarisés 7 une proposition est
essentielle dans la lutte contre contre
les inégalités et sur la question de
l'éducation prioritaire d'ailleurs on
attend toujours la réforme de
l'éducation prioritaire puisque vous
arrivez en bout de quinquennat et que
via et qu' il n'y a rien eu de fait
pendant ces cinq ans si la chose qui
fait la chose que vous avez c'est que
vous avez intégré dans le financement de
l'éducation prioritaire des
établissements privés qui ne remplissent
pas ces mêmes obligations
de 200 trigance
expérimente aussi cool jamais nommé vous
avez mais vous savez
sont dans les débats aujourd'hui sur la
question d'éducation prioritaire le
bilan de monsieur macro fait un bilan
qui est
sûre les sur les réformes enfin sur les
propositions pour être plus précis un
mode réponse là dessus sur les propos
mensongers de monsieur trigance
évidemment que non l'expérimentation qui
est fait justement qui vise à donner de
nouveaux moyens madame darcos puisque
vous dites qu'il n'ya que l'éducation
prioritaire à de nouveaux élèves et à de
nouveaux territoires parce que j'ai à
coeur bien sûr de répondre à tous les
élèves où qu'il soit sur le territoire
je suis très sensible aux zones rurales
dont vous parliez précédemment et bien
cette expérimentation est financé sur un
budget propre ça veut dire que le budget
de l'éducation prioritaire n'a
aucunement était entravé en revanche je
veux bien que l'on revienne
effectivement sur la proposition de
madame hidalgo qui dans un premier temps
nous propose de doubler le salaire des
professeurs alors on a fait l'estimation
de là la de la mesure on estime à
environ 30 milliards par an sur un
quinquennat ça fait 150 milliards ça
c'est nous au niveau de la majorité
présidentielle yannick jadot a regardé
la proposition ils l'estiment lui à 40
milliards jean luc parant jean luc
mélenchon l'estiment à 60 milliards donc
c'est totalement démagogique voilà alors
donc moi je veux bien qu'on discute et
effectivement de la rémunération des
professeurs parce que nous avons mis en
place un grenelle de l'éducation et
j'affirme aujourd'hui que les
professeurs qui entrent dans le métier
gagne déjà 186 euros vous avez joué les
attentes de machad lalo belkacem vous
les avez gelé jean michel blanquer les a
gelé quand il est arrivé vous n'avez pas
augmenter les
vous allez je dérange vous avait gelé ou
pas les accords de najat vallaud
belkacem ce qu'on appelle entre
guillemets les ppcr toutes les
organisations syndicales les avaient
validées et la première chose que
monsieur blanc caire a fait quand il est
arrivé 1 et ringo reese a supprimé mer
comme il a supprimé si le club de metz
place merci
d'avancé oui bien sûr mais sur la
proposition des salaires cette
proposition tient toujours mais bien sûr
mais il a rappelé qu'au matin
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui la réalité des
choses c'est que les enseignants en
france et c'est une réalité un
professeur aujourd'hui en allemagne ou
en pays nordiques gagne deux fois plus
qu'un enseignant et donc anne hidalgo
propose alors qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
70 % des professeurs des écoles et 50%
des certifiés qui gagnent moins de 2500
euros nets et quand je dis cela ces
primes et heures sup comprise donc la
proposition qui est faite par anne
hidalgo et qui est budgétée c'est alors
que la situation d'aujourd'hui un
enseignant commence à 1700 euros il
finit à 2005
c'est d'aller
je vous ai pas couper une fois de plus
c'est quand même bien du gouvernement
c'est un peu prat un peu particulier
gens m'aiment et donc la proposition
c'est précisément de démarrer à 2300
euros et non les vu la durée du quinté
voilà absolument est d'ailleurs
j'observe il ya une enquête très
intéressante qui est sorti aujourd'hui
qui est dans un grand quotidien du soir
quand même 7 % des profs de collège
estiment que leur profession
est n'est pas reconnue et vous avez 92%
des enseignants qui considèrent qu'ils
ne sont pas ou peu reconnue par les
politiques et 94% par l'opinion publique
ça signifie aujourd'hui que la question
de la revalorisation
s'inscrit dans une relève et ima sion
alors du corps enseignant des données
aussi positif le taux de satisfaction
des enseignants c'est une enquête csa
qui a été menée pour le sénat 25 %
s'estiment reconnus dans leurs efforts
22% seulement s'estiment satisfaits de
leur rémunération
et puis un autre indicateur qui est très
important c'est la hausse des démissions
chez les enseignants + 40 % en cinq ans
dans le premier degré jean frédéric
poisson vous a pas entendu depuis à un
moment je reviens vers vous parce que
avec reg zimmo voulait changer le
système de rémunération des enseignants
notamment avec des primes au mérite
c'est ça
oui pas de raison que les on sait qu'on
soit presque enfin une des catégories
c'est pas tout à fait ça mais
on va apprendre des choses à l'envers le
les enseignants ne sont pas éligibles à
ce genre de gratification alors que
beaucoup de fonctionnaires qu'ils soient
d'état des collectivités locales ou de
la santé publique peuvent avoir accès à
des rémunérations sous forme de
gratification ça fait partie des
dispositifs que comment dire le futur
gouvernement on doit pouvoir discuter
avec les syndicats pour savoir comment
tout ça va se mettre en place et je
pense effectivement que la
revalorisation des salaires mais je
crois qu'il ya un accord assez général
sur ce point doit être repéré mais
j'observe que il y a dans la le mal-être
des deux beaucoup d'enseignants
évidemment des conditions de
rémunérations qui sont en pause mais
également leurs conditions de travail je
veux dire par là je rejoins tout à fait
ce que disait mon collègue de trigance
tout à l'heure on n'enseigne pas et moi
j'étais enseignant comme d'ailleurs un
certain nombre d'entre nous sur le
plateau je sais bien qu'on n'enseigne
pas dans une place de quart ont commencé
dans une tasse de 15 et tout cela doit
s'apprendre donc l'accompagnement la
formation est quelque chose qui doit
l'être aussi
évidemment parfaitement organisé et de
la même façon on n'enseigne pas non plus
dans une classe dont le niveau est
homogène
versus est une pièce dans laquelle le
niveau ne l'est pas et plus il ya de
disparités entre comment dire les
capacités des élèves à recevoir un
savoir dans une même salle de classe et
plus l'enseignement est difficile et
donc il faut faire attention à ce que
c'est cette homogénéisation du niveau il
faut pas avoir peur de d'affirmer que
tous les enfants n'ont pas au même
moment même capacité d'apprendre des
savoirs fondamentaux au même rythme à la
même vitesse dans tout ça vous faites
comment
homogénéiser ses classes c'est comment
comment faites-vous pour au moins j'ai
réalisé et qui vous laisser sur le bord
du chemin certaines phases mais j'ai
ramené sur le bord du chemin monsieur
même quand j'étais au collège je me
souviens que il y avait des classes de
niveaux en sixième et ce jusqu'en
troisième par exemple et que alors c'est
difficile à faire dans une école
primaire c'est évident surtout dans des
villages ruraux où il ya souvent
d'ailleurs plusieurs classes leur niveau
dans une même salle de classe mais à
partir du collège le fhaine de rétablir
des classes de niveau nous paraît une
forme d'évidence là encore ça
participerait à une amélioration des
conditions d'enseignement pour beaucoup
d'enseignants en particulier les
professeurs de collèges et je voudrais
dire simplement at il pas une autre à
madame les limaces que quand on a
dépensé plus de 500 milliards dont on
n'avait pas le premier centime pendant
un quinquennat on ne devrait pas être à
30 milliards très
voulait répondre
moi les provocations d'eric zemmour des
représentants d'eric zemmour non
franchement moi je je je vais revenir
plus tôt sur la revalorisation puisque
je crois que c'est un point qui est
partagé par l'ensemble des intervenants
aujourd'hui
cependant nous intérim les profs ont
subi un déclassement en 40 ans en 1980
le salaire d'entrée d'un prof au collège
c'était 2,2 fois le smic aujourd'hui
c'est
1,2 rues de nyc 1,2 oui oui donc on est
on est vraiment voilà si vous faites un
bilan en terme de rémunération je veux
bien faire un bilan mais dans ce cas là
faut le faire dans le temps parce que ce
que vous me dites là ça ne date pas de
2010 est bien d'accord qu'il ya une
évolution dans leur essence et c'est
évidemment ce que l'on est en train
d'inverser je les dis à travers le
grenelle de l'éducation en revalorisant
notamment dans l'entrée dans la carrière
donc on est plus à 1700 désormais et les
professeurs qui démarre sont aujourd'hui
à 1869 euros c'est déjà une progression
est l'objectif que nous nous sommes
fixés c'est de faire démarrer ses
professeurs à 2000 euros donc ça se fera
je l'espère en tout cas dans le prochain
quinquennat il ya une autre qu'il ya un
autre point qui a été abordé par par
tous les intervenants c'est celui de
l'autonomie des établissements c'est
notamment un plan non pardon je vous
interromps parce que je devais en temps
lors de pardon à jour dans la parole
évidemment à biars darcos sur la
question de la rémunération
qu'est ce que vous proposez on voudrait
pouvoir valoriser au moins 10% des faits
et les salaires ça paraît peu mais en
pour répondre aussi un peu aux attaques
sur l'époque de nicolas sarkozy
on est et on était dans les fameux
rgpp qui a été une claque pour beaucoup
de ministres il fallait en effet ne pas
reconduire un fonctionnaire sur deux
parties à la retraite et en fait on a
fait surtout essayer de 2 to be mais de
ne pas renouveler des administratifs et
je pense qu'on a encore la possibilité
de continuer à avoir moins de personnels
administratifs comme c'est le cas aussi
à l'hôpital ou dans d'autres dans
d'autres secteurs et par contre du coup
permettre de mieux valoriser les
professeurs moi je reviens et c'est
aussi ça va être comme ça la suite
honnêtement les professeurs ont besoin
d'être soutenus par leur hiérarchie mais
surtout il ya de jeu tous les jours moi
des professeurs qui me disent on a
mobilisé ma mobilité j'ai l'impression
de parler à un mur a parlé à quelque
chose de tellement une technostructure
tellement lourde que j'aimerais pouvoir
parler à mon directeur d'établissement
voir à mon directeur académique moi j'ai
un directeur d'accueil académique je
voudrais échanger contre personne qui
est absolument formidable et qui lui
même très conscient de tout ça on le dit
là avec la période qu'ovide j'ai des
vacataires qui sont prêts à pouvoir
reprendre du service et qui n'ont pas la
possibilité pour le moment parce qu'on
n'a pas à appuyer sur le bon bouton le
la centrale n'a pas renvoyé la
possibilité d'avoir tel ou tel poste
c'est très compliqué et en fait ça d une
amie d humaine humanis complètement les
relations entre les professeurs alors
c'est plus une rémunération une
revalorisation simplement financière
mais dans leur vie tous les jours et
dans
leur travail et leur évolution ils ont
besoin d'avoir des as tu des acteurs
locaux régionaux départementaux et
locaux qui puissent les aider en fait
vous l'avez d'algos comment vous
l'évaluez est ce que maintenant oui je
pense que c'est malheureusement c'est un
monde idéal bien évidemment et c'est
vrai que ces chiffres sont épouvantables
parce que au départ le professeur
l'enseignant était bien évidemment une
des personnes les plus importantes dans
un village c'était un aux tables
vraiment enfin c'était quelqu'un qui
avait qui avait au delà du savoir qui
avait en effet réussi on voit bien
aujourd'hui que les recrutements sont
compliqués moi ce qui me fait peur
aujourd'hui au delà de la valorisation
des enseignants actuels c'est ce qui va
se passer demain c'est en effet on
n'arrive pas à trouver un moyen de
revaloriser ces métiers et je pense que
la violence notamment et le manque de
respect vis-à-vis des professeurs des
familles et du contexte actuel fait
qu'ils n'ont pas envie non plus de venir
dans les classes parce que et qu'ils
changent de métier rapidement parce
qu'ils ont eu un peu un idéal de la
solaire est la réponse principale non
mais est ce que c'est le frein jeune je
pense que c'est quand même une partie de
le frein mais vous avez aussi quand même
qualité entre guillemets de rythme de
vie qui est approprié d'ailleurs plus
pour ça c'est très féminisés aux femmes
parce que vous avez aussi une période
des vacances scolaires et c'est plus
facile pour pour avoir une vie de
famille mais même si vous avez quand
même des cours à préparer il faut jamais
l'oublier mais honnêtement c'est
absolument irréaliste
très rapide c'est très intéressant vos
remarques sur le caractère irréaliste
d'abord un tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire qu'il faut les revaloriser et
2 1 nous avons fait nos preuves parce
que je vous rappelle qu'en 2012
j'entendais la même chose lorsque nous
avions proposiez la création de 60000
postes dans l'éducation nationale tout
le monde nous disait ça n'est pas
possible achat réalité les que ça change
et la réalité sur la réalité la réalité
c'est que nous avons créé ces soixante
mille postes donc j'entends aujourd'hui
tu changes et j'en ai huit j'entends
changer tout le monde les regarde
valorisé mais que lorsqu'il ya des
propositions qui aillent revalorisation
on nous dit c'est impossible
parce que l'aspect disent inchangées sur
les mrc je reviendrai sur l'attractivité
parce que vous avez raison il avait
fallu la question du salaire vous avez
tout à fait raison et on va passer à un
autre thème parce qu'il faut étudier
quelques propositions des différents
candidats et je voudrais qu'on revienne
sur une proposition d'eric zemmour il ya
des primes au mérite pour les
enseignants la di la fin de
l'apprentissage des langues étrangères à
l'école primaire et ce retour de la
blouse on écoutait vous et moi
eric zemmour tout de suite
est un symbole c'est un symbole de quoi
deux choses 1 ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire l'école est un
sanctuaire donc on oublie la mode etc et
2 on
supprime les différences sociales je
trouve ça assez beau moi derrière la
blouse ou même l'uniforme vous avez
raison c'est c'est la même logique en
vérité c'est les enfants sont tous les
mêmes sont tous égaux ils sont là pour
apprendre pour
vous savez hannah arendt entre belle
formule a dit que chaque génération
d'enfants est une génération de barbare
qu'il faut civiliser et nous avons
oublié depuis 30 ans depuis 40 ans de
les civiliser nous devons les re
civilisé
monsieur poisson chat et un poisson la
blouse la blouse on se dit c'est au
mieux de ce talent j copie réactionnaire
comment comment vous analyser cette
proposition ni ni nostalgique ni
réactionnaire dans tous les
environnements dans lesquels
comment dire il ya des enjeux à la fois
d'apprentissage collectif de cohésion de
respect mutuel dans beaucoup de ces
environnements il y à la pratique d'une
forme de voiture unique qui prend
différentes formes
l'armée ces uniformes dans certaines
entreprises ça passe par quelque chose
qui relève de vêtements qui sont
identiques ou similaires
l'affirmation du principe d'égalité par
ce symbole qui est vestimentaire qu'il
ne compte pas pour rien en faisant que
les élèves porte une blouse d'abord ça
protège de retraitement premièrement
c'était en tout cas ce que nous a connu
quand nous étions platine ou à l'école
et deuxièmement comme le disait très
bien le risque pour l'instant c'est une
chose qui permet d'affirmer qu
effectivement tous les élèves sont égaux
devant anciennement qu'on leur donne
et d'affirmer par un symbole qui est
visible c'est aussi simple que ça il n'y
a aucune espèce de nid de nostalgie de
en quoi d'ailleurs ce serait
réactionnaire comment va très bien le
l'adjectif n'est rien de rien d'illégal
là dedans il ya rien y faire état d'un
retour en arrière ses volets sonner si
vous voyez ce que je veux retour en
arrière cher monsieur nous apprenons la
langue de nos ancêtres elle existe
depuis au moins bien avant leur donnant
ce de l'ida retrait au 16e siècle est la
langue officielle de la france depuis le
16e siècle nous avons le nombre de nos
enseignes a pas de retour en arrière
c'est simplement le fait que c'est un
des moyens de s'attaquer à quelques une
des grosses difficultés que rencontrent
l'enseignement aujourd'hui
particulièrement enseignement au
primaire c'est-à-dire cette difficulté
que nous avons à traiter comment dire
d'un des groupes d'enfants d'une manière
qui soit à la fois respectueuse de ce
qu'ils sont et qu'ils apprennent à se
respecter entre de ses possibles de
manière d'apprendre le respect du genre
darcos la blouse
excusez moi monsieur poisson mais je
j'aurais pu y est d'accord avec vous il
ya quelques temps mais là on est en
train voiliers de discuter la fin d'une
proposition de loi sur le harcèlement et
le cyber harcèlement scolaire je pense
que blues ou pas blues ça n'est pas
possible qu'aujourd'hui et des jeunes
qui se suicident pour pour des
harcèlement scolaire et ça n'est pas du
tout mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le
fait d'être habillée de manière uniforme
ou pas je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
fractures au sein de l'établissement
entre élèves ou entre élèves et
professeurs n'a plus rien à voir là où
je suis peut-être plus et j'étais assez
fier que ce soit d'ailleurs des
propositions qu'on avait fait nous au
sénat qui est des drapeaux français pas
simplement dans tous les établissements
mais dans toutes les classes donc on se
retrouve derrière le mot de donation de
ce que ça représente très publique comme
en son temps il ya eu la charte de la
laïcité avec monsieur peillon ça je
reconnais tout à fait pour moi le
l'uniforme dans ce que ça de devoir être
comment dire rassembleur par rapport à
notre école de la république oui mais
aujourd'hui enfin franchement parler de
blues alors qu'on a ces problèmes dans
la misère de violence ou de violence
scolaire c'est comme aller on va un peu
décalé on va clore ce débat avec
un élément qui est peut-être là la
hantise de tous les ministres de
l'éducation et qui sera certainement
regarder de très près par la future
équipe gouvernementale
c'est le classement pisa ce classement
pisa qui évalue les compétences des
collégiens dans les pays de l' ocde
j'appelle laurent mauriac à me rejoindre
bonsoir laurent rédacteur en chef de
brief me alors ces évaluations pisa
elles sont effectivement crainte par les
par les responsables politiques c'est
quoi oui alors pisa
ccc organisé tous les trois ans donc
c'est une évaluation qui
qui qui porte sur trois domaines la
compréhension de l'écrit les maths et
les sciences la prochaine aura lieu en
mai prochain 85 pays doivent y
participer au total 8000 élèves français
seront mobilisés l'évaluation dure trois
heures trente ça se fait avec un
ordinateur alors en 2018 dernière
édition en date la france se situe et
une fois encore dans la moyenne des pays
comparables est loin derrière le canada
la finlande ou l'irlande mais elle était
assez proche de l'allemagne alors je
sais pas si on peut voir les éléments
d'infographie quand vous ne les les
présenter est-ce que c'est utile pisa
oui c'est utile parce que c'est un outil
de mesure internationale qui permet de
faire des comparaisons à intervalles
réguliers d'évaluer les progrès et dans
son programme de 2010 est d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron citer les dernières
enquêtes pisa sur les inégalités pour
nourrir son programme est ce qu'il ya
des limites des critiques qu'on te faire
à cet été oui alors plusieurs chercheurs
jugent l'évaluation trop uniforme ce
qu'elle porte sur 80 pays et donc il
estime que c'est des pays trop
différents pour pouvoir être comparés de
cette manière une autre limite concerne
le fait d'insister dans chaque
commentaire sur la notion d'oran où deux
ou deux classements pisa alors qu'en
fait des écarts sont souvent faibles
entre les pays mais il faut bien sûr
prendre en compte ses limites pisa ainsi
tout de même les pays à se poser des
questions sur leur système éducatif et
sur son amélioration et au delà des
polémiques à chaud qui interviennent à
l'annonce de chaque nouvelle édition
cette étude joue un rôle majeur dans le
débat public et la prochaine elle aura
lieu en mai 1027 a été repoussée elle a
été repoussée d'un an à cause du coc
vite donc prochaine évaluation en mai
2022 et résultats du jour mois après
merci beaucoup merci laurent mauriac
pardon vous avoir un peu bousculé et
merci de vous être adapté le rédacteur
en chef de brief me natali et limaces on
va juger aussi le bilan de ce
quinquennat sur cette évaluation d'après
vous l'évaluation peas à venir la
capacité de remonter je rejouais jusqu
en regard d'une
si elles évidemment mais on est 23e en
lecture on a perdu 8 places depuis 2000
25e en maths ou moins quatorze places
25e en culture scientifique mois d'août
ces chiffres on la sait de quelle année
abbas et la dernière évaluation en 2018
2018 voilà donc on verra effectivement
en 2022
oui si effectivement l'impact de tout ce
que nous avons mis en place de toutes
les réformes parce qu'on a parlé du
dédoublement n'en a pas parlé de la
réforme du bac de la réforme de la voie
professionnelle
voilà évidemment oui on aurait pu parler
du lycée
du lycée longuement des mathématiques en
effet parce qu'on a subi un certain
nombre d' attaques ces derniers jours
sur le niveau des mathématiques qui
serait plus faible mais là encore c'est
totalement démagogique bien sûr puisque
avec la réforme du bac jusque justement
ont fait plus de menthe et ont fait
mieux de maths et je vous affirme qu'il
n'ya même plus de filles aujourd'hui qui
sont engagés dans les mathématiques avec
la réforme du contraire
regardez
[Musique]
question reconnaît il lapierre match
rien de continuer dans sa lancée
l'émission et c'est moi qui prend la
main pour vous remercier les uns et les
autres merci je remercie d'être sur moi
parce que c'est la fin de l'émission et
donc je voudrais remercier toutes les
équipes de public sénat merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat et je vous
donne rendez-vous lundi